[Music]
what makes gone such a controversial
protagonist
on the surface hunter hunter yoshihiro
togashi's long-running magnum opus
is a standard shonen story each story
arc focuses on a well-worn shonen trope
such as a training sequence or a
tournament arc things that togashi has
covered before in his serious yoyo haku
show
but where hunter hunter fundamentally
differs from the status quo
is the way that it takes these formulas
and then breaks them apart in
interesting ways before once again
returning to its shown in roots
in a 2018 interview with weekly
showninja magazine
togashi revealed that with gon he
originally planned to create a sort of
good boy type of character
that would and i quote win every
character i would want for
some competition but as soon as he
started writing his story
he immediately realized that this sort
of character
would not fit the story he had
envisioned at all
after all what type of good boy would
light-heartedly
and without so much as a second thought
abandon his foster mother to become a
hunter
and then search for his father who left
him behind as a child
just to follow his own selfish path and
so it was
at that point back in 1998 when the
series published its very first chapter
that he decided to try something a
little bit different
he came to the conclusion that the
traditional tropes of shonen manga
would not work for the world he was
about to create and so he decided to
twist the general perspective on the
genre
in a number of unimposing but at the
same time highly impactful ways
as a result gone is not your classic
all-good all-powerful shonen hero but
rather a realistic version of it
that has to face real consequences for
his actions within the story world that
togashi has thrown him in
thus he has become one of the most
controversially discussed shonen
protagonists in history
and in this video i want to explore with
you why i believe
that it makes gon one of the most well
written shonen heroes
of all time
before we can dissect how togashi has
designed gone as a character
and what makes his take on the trope of
shonen protagonists so unique
we first have to understand the general
theme of hunter hunter as a series
overall
you might have heard before that the
main theme of hunter hunter is morality
and exploring the thin lines between
good and evil black and white
and it's undeniably true that morality
is a central part of the story's premise
however i still believe that the actual
theme of the story
goes even further than this because the
theme
otherwise also known as the moral
argument of a story
contrary to common belief doesn't refer
to a general subject matter such as love
class power or good vs evil now it much
rather is the author's view on how to
act in the world
and therefore also encompasses a certain
moral vision
that the author wants to explore
throughout his story
therefore by definition i believe that
morality as a general concept
cannot be the overall theme of hunter
hunter but much rather
is a part of it the actual moral
argument that togashi's exploring in the
story
and that he also uses to explore shonen
as a genre overall
is what does it mean to be human in a
superhuman world
and this overall theme then includes
other important questions
such as what does it mean to hold power
and
ultimately also what does it mean to be
moral
if you look closely enough each
character in the story
is a variation of that theme and that's
exactly
what i want to explore with you in this
series of videos and i hope you enjoy
watching them just as much as i enjoyed
making them
so why start with gone well gone is of
course the protagonist of the story
however hunter hunter takes a slightly
different conceptual approach to their
character web
than other typical shonen do no matter
if it's naruto
bleach or one piece amidst a usually
very well-crafted group of supporting
main characters
the hero always stands out clearly as
the central focus point of the story
therefore naruto is about naruto himself
becoming hokage
bleach is about ichigo following his
destiny as a shinigami
and exploring the supernatural world and
one piece is of course about luffy
striving to find the one piece and
becoming king of the pirates
but what about hunter hunter while gone
does have a central desire within his
ambition to find his father jing
that is driving the story forward it is
neither particularly intense
nor is it very urgent the story has
no overarching big evil to defeat no
central and important object to be
acquired and no final destination to be
reached
rather than following a straight line
towards a major goal
gon and his friends follow a meandering
path without apparent direction
they cover a great deal of territory in
a half-hazard way
and encounter a variety of characters
from different levels of society
at the same time and in close relation
to this in hunter hunter the lines
between protagonist and ally become
very very thin so thin even that it's
fair to say that the story has not one
but two protagonists
gone and kilua with gone being only a
tad more important this trope of the
buddy story
is quite commonly found in hollywood
movies from stories like the lord of the
rings
over 21 jump street all the way to
pretty much
any love story out there being a typical
example of this
but it is very very rare in shown in
anime and manga
in a buddy story in essence the hero is
split into two parts
with one being a bit more relevant than
the other and both main characters
having two different backgrounds
two different approaches to life and two
different sets of values and talents
as a result the whole becomes greater
than the sum of its parts
and that's exactly what makes the
combination gone and kiloa
such a strong leading duo these two
protagonists are allies throughout the
course of the series
but at the same time also have an
overarching conflict of values and
actions
that gives character development to both
of them so as you can see
gone is already fundamentally different
from other typical shonen protagonists
simply based on his role in the story
his desire to find his father is not
particularly intense
and he shares the role of the hero with
his body kiluah
who has his very own set of desires and
weaknesses
and we will get further into their
relationship in the next video
now this insight of the split hero can
be
boiled down even further to one of
hunter hunter's major strength as a
story
while many writers believe that all you
need is a well written hero
that is the only person that really
matters hunter hunter
doesn't live from any individual
character but rather from an intricately
crafted web of characters that interact
with each other
as a result the main group of
protagonists move the plot along
but they don't carry it all by
themselves and thus
every single character that togashi
introduces helps to define those around
them
so now that we've looked at the general
premise for god's role in the story
and how it differs from conventional
shonen heroes
let's finally talk about his character
arc
at the beginning of the story gone is
the stereotypical shonen poster boy
young plucky irrepressible spiky hair
in the first 20 or so episodes he's
basically son goku
without the tail he's seemingly nothing
but good-natured
and depending on your preference as a
viewer his simple and pure attitude was
probably either incredibly charming
or almost intolerable to watch his main
desire is to find his father jing
and prove himself in the world of
hunters both of which he strongly
idealizes
equipped with immense talent power and
skill
he leaves the isolated island he was
raised on to take the hunter exam and
follow his dreams
what togashi basically does here is make
us believe that gon
just as so many other popular shonen
characters will grow to become a warrior
of justice
fighting for what is right he gives us
the impression that in this story
it will be easy to distinguish who are
the good guys and who are the baddies
wearing capes
just as we've been trained to expect
from so many other stories from that
generation
however it quickly becomes clear that
the world of hunter hunter is quite
cruel and unforgiving actions and
mistakes have
real consequences here and togashi
basically uses gon
as a sort of literary guinea pig to see
what would happen to your typical shonen
hero
if you were to throw them into a
realistic world
and so slowly but steadily as we pass
from arc to arc to get to see more and
more of the world
and god's interaction with it it becomes
clearer and clearer
that what now separates gun the most
from other shonen protagonists
is his increasingly skewed moral compass
the fundamental lie that gone believes
about the world
is that everything is either black or
white
and that there is a clear line between
good and evil
but since that is not how the real world
works where morality is mostly found on
the spectrum of gray
gone increasingly struggles to define
what is good and what is bad
based on the childish nativity that an
11 year old simply has
and so since objectively judging
people's complex actions and behavior
makes it very difficult to put them into
one category or the other
gon bases his morality on himself and
his relationship with a person
people he's familiar with such as kilua
leorio or kurapika
are obviously good and worthy of his
protection while unfamiliar people dying
during the hunter exam
are generally ignored and not considered
as important
meanwhile people gone is unfamiliar with
but that conduct
acts of violence and cruelty must
obviously be bad
this can strongly be seen when gun gets
captured by the phantom troop
as he despises them for taking innocent
lives unrelated to them
and at the same time gone also
categorizes people based on whether or
not they're useful to him or his friends
next to his naivety this selfishness is
gone's second major weakness as a
character
as a result his morality appears to
become increasingly skewed
where an objectively evil and twisted
character like benolds
who has massacred and eaten countless
people
is actually thanked by gone simply for
helping him getting stronger
to better understand this development in
gon and how his story ultimately reached
the dark climax it did
i think the best thing is to look at the
central relationship between hero
and opponent
i think it's pretty fair to say that
gone's relationship with hisoka
is to hunter hunter what unnecessarily
dramatic music
is to this channel without it it just
wouldn't feel the same
so when we first get introduced to
hisoka togashi promises us the typical
shonen good guy takes on bad guy
relationship between him
and gone hisoka is a psychopathic clown
and the apex of hedonism
who cuts off another contestant's arms
simply for bumping into him
right at the start of the hunter exam he
will stop at nothing to get what he
wants
no matter the damage it does to himself
or others
as a result at the beginning of their
relationship gone and hisoka appear to
be clear-cut
opposites right down to hisoka's
appearance as a scary bloodthirsty clown
which as we all know is the mortal enemy
of kids everywhere
nonetheless despite all their seeming
differences over the course of the story
both characters find themselves
inextricably drawn to each other
what started off as our typical good
hero vs evil opponent dynamic
slowly blurs into an uncomfortable
similarity between the two
their shared desire to better themselves
through combat
and their ecstatic enjoyment of battle
is nothing unique to hunter hunter
however most shonen tend to shy away
from so blatantly highlighting this
objectively problematic stance of their
main character
togashi on the other hand makes it easy
to imagine
a small misstep in gon's life pushing
him into a position
similar to hisokas and we can see this
in the story in a number of ways
the best example for this however might
be hisoka's fight in the heavens arena
against the overconfident castro simply
to prove his superiority and provide a
show
hisoka sacrifices both his arms to gain
the upper hand
no pun intended and to satisfy his
desire to dominate and humiliate his
opponent
then a little later during the greed
island arc
gone mirrors this morbid sacrifice
against the bomber genthru
he abandons a carefully thought-out plan
by taking an explosive attack from
genthru
which results in him losing an arm
basically for
no other reason but his desire to prove
his superiority
and humiliate his opponents and so in a
weird way
gone and hizoka become more and more
similar throughout the story
to the point where hizoka almost
functions as a sort of mentor for gone
a dynamic that we'll be exploring in
more detail in another video
now however we can finally look at what
gun's character arc looks like
overall
to summarize what we've been discussing
so far gone's character arc shows us
what happens to a naive 11 year old boy
that holds enormous physical power when
he's increasingly confronted with the
harsh and cruel reality
of the real world this is basically the
coming of age storyline we know from
other shonen such as naruto
only that gone doesn't have a positive
arc
but a negative one instead of growing
more emotionally and morally mature
his character is slowly crushed by the
brutal reality of the hunter hunter
world
this twist on the always rising shonen
protagonist
had not been explored in this much
detail before and has led to the very
mature vibe
hunter hunter carries as a series the
premise for gon's development throughout
the story
as we've already discussed are his
naivety and his selfishness
both of these things don't necessarily
make him a bad person
but simply an inexperienced and
overwhelmed child
nonetheless based on these weaknesses
gone's character
is set up to learn about the complex
moral fabric of society
and form a more realistic view of the
world this need is also moral
since through his basic moral compass
and his nativity
combined with his enormous power he
starts to hurt people around him
however it is not until the chimera and
arc
that gon completely spirals into a
complete loss of his morality
and ultimately his humanity there are
two events in particular towards the
beginning of the arc
that are representative for this change
the first is gone's first
ever kill in the story a low-ranked
armadillo chimera ant
that bluntly attacks him and had gone
then slowly crushes to death
while it is definitely understandable
that gon defends himself
and maybe even has to kill the chimera
and the complete
lack of reaction and emotional response
to this act
is what is truly shocking here the pure
gone we got to know at the beginning of
the story
would never have been able to do such a
thing at least not without being deeply
affected by it
and yet here gone has already been so
consumed by power and violence
that not only is he unshaken by his
first kill but he doesn't even give it a
second thought
and even more impactful for his
character is the death of his mentor
kite
who is killed by the royal guard pitot
this first ever loss of a loved person
affects gone deeply way more than is
common for typical shonen characters
much rather gone has a very realistic
and human response to this event
and develops a rage and thirst for
revenge against pito
that is honestly quite unsettling to
watch
as a result his final act in the arc is
one of the most notorious events in
shonen manga
he uses the heavily injured and innocent
komugi
as a mere tool to blackmail pitou giving
no second thought about the overall
situation
and threatening to kill her once he
learns that kite is beyond help
in order to satisfy his wrath against
pitot he calls upon
all of the potential energy he will ever
have for a short bout of combat
where he brutally kills his opponent
without a single shred of remorse
in doing so he trades the rest of his
life
for one short moment of violence as the
horrified kiluah
is unable to do anything but watch it's
some of the most harrowing reading of
watching in the genre
a perverse version of goku's spirit bomb
this is gone's moment of moral choice
but instead of having a self-revelation
about what it means to be human
and how to behave justly and morally
towards others in the situation
he gives in to his worst instincts as
kilua abandons his merciless past by
forging a relationship with gone
his friend sacrifices all of his
remaining humanity
for the ultimate act of revenge and
becoming a monster in the process
the self-revelation meant forgone in
this moment of extreme moral and human
complexity
is so obvious that we the readers have
it instead
and it makes the scene just the more
dark and uncomfortable to watch
the reason why this dark twist on the
typical shonen protagonist arc
works so well with gone is because
togashi has followed one of the most
important rules of writing when creating
his character
creating empathy but not sympathy
creating sympathy for a character means
that we approve of the hero's actions
and completely identify with him as a
person if that were to be true however
we could never have morally challenging
and interesting main characters
and every single story would only serve
a very limited and specific audience
that shares the exact same views and
values as the hero
empathy on the other hand means that
while we don't necessarily approve of
the heroes actions
we do however understand them we
understand why the hero would make this
decision
and how he ultimately reached that moral
conclusion
and as you might suspect foreshadowing
plays a crucial role in this
it makes the story cohesive and engaging
so
when we apply this to gone while his
brutal murder of pito
and his failure to keep his humanity are
devastating to watch
we do fully understand why gon is
behaving this way
and does feel like we're watching the
natural climax to his character arc
his entire journey has slowly built
towards this dramatic moment
and we could unconsciously witness gon's
creeping moral decline
without togashi having to throw it into
our faces
this is truly great writing
it is a great endpoint to the story
where gon ultimately
meets his father and is judged worthy of
traveling with him
in a twisted way he has managed to
fulfill his desire
and going back to the traditional tropes
of shonen togashi establishes a new
equilibrium here
and as the author stated himself at this
point in hunter hunter
where gon meets jing he has pretty much
already completed the story once now you
may rightfully say
doesn't hunter hunter keep going
afterwards and of course
you're right however as you might know
if you follow the manga
gone is not really currently part of the
story and should he ever appear in it
again in the form of a main character
he will need a completely fresh arc with
a new desire line
and now possibly a positive character
arc where he
re-evaluates his past actions and
ultimately regains his humanity
ending up better and wiser than at the
beginning of the story
the one who enabled gon second chance
and survival meanwhile
was his best friend kirua who started
off as the cold-blooded and inhuman
assassin at the beginning of the story
who has now completely changed places
with gone
in many ways kilua is written just as
fantastically as gon
and we'll be looking at his character
and role in the story in the next video
of the series
so stay tuned for that thanks guys peace